i i wanted to include this because it
very much plays into
what we just talked about especially at
the end there of the monologue uh the
real purpose of education
which is to convert your kids
you know it's it's a it's a for for the
left public education is religious
education it's all about
conversion and um here is
uh it and and most of the time on the
left they'll deny that or they'll try to
go
try to kind of use euphemisms they don't
want to speak directly about it and
admit
that yeah we want your kids we want to
convert them
and make them into the kinds of people
that we think they should be
usually they they skirt around that
subject they're not going to be so blunt
and straightforward about it
but every once in a while they'll come
out and and admit it
and sometimes do that in the form of
song so
i got to play this with you for you uh
to begin with this is the san francisco
gay men's chorus
as they're called and they've apparently
been around for a long time
this is a a a video they put out on on
youtube it's
titled a message from the gay community
and uh anyway here's the message let's
listen you think we're sinful
you fight against our rights you say we
all lead lives you can't respect
but you're just frightened you think
that we'll corrupt your kids if our
agenda goes unchecked
it's funny just this once you're correct
we'll convert your children
happens bit by bit quietly and subtly
and you will barely notice it
you can keep them from disco warn about
san francisco
make him wear pleated pants we don't
care
we'll convert your children
we'll make them tolerant and fair there
you go
uh that's that is
ultimately the goal now we we also have
okay we'll play this clip for you real
quick too because then
the song goes on i'm not gonna play the
whole thing for you um
but i think the creepiest part of the
whole song you probably thought that it
couldn't get creepier than that well
it does here you go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing weird about that bunch of grown
men saying we're coming for your
children
what else do you need to know they're
literally they've put it in song
they're singing it to you we're coming
for your children
yep we are we'll get we got a whole song
and dance about it
yeah even in spite of this there are
still people
even people on the right a lot of people
on the right actually
when you use a phrase like the lgbt
agenda they kind of recoil they say whoa
whoa
yeah this is that's conspiracy that's
offensive
it's right there it's not for me it's
it's this
you just heard it you heard the song
they've got us they've got an anthem now
making it very clear
um the only problem with a phrase like
the lgbt agenda is that it's
it's it's this is all it's redundant i
mean the left's agenda is the lgbt
agenda
is the critical race theory agenda all
of this is together
but they could not be more clear about
it they're coming for your children
and the way that they justify it is is
they say well we we want to make them
tolerant and fair we want to make them
open-minded
of course it's going to be our idea of
what tolerant and fair means
and as we know uh
this is not going to be universal
tolerance because they're not going to
be tolerant
we don't want your kids to be tolerant
of of everything we don't even want to
be tolerant of you
we want to turn your kids against you
no we want them to be tolerant of of us
and the choices that we make and not so
much tolerant as
uh as celebratory is really the word
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends